facebook removes two separate
conservative ads for violating the
scruples of fake fact checkers at
politifact
joe biden pushes anti-vaccine propaganda
as trump fights with his cdc director
and kamala harris pushed a bail fund
that bailed out some rather unsavory
characters
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from prying eyes at
expressvpn.com we'll get to all the news
of the day and plenty of news there is
we'll get to all of it in a second first
let's talk about all the money that you
are giving away with your cell phone
bill i mean
lots and lots of money a lot of that is
because you bought the unlimited data
package didn't you
didn't you and in doing so you're paying
way too much money
for your cell phone coverage what if i
told you that you could have the exact
same coverage as you know like at t
verizon t-mobile same internet cable
utility
like all of the stuff that you need from
these places
except you'd be paying like a lot less
money pure talk gives you the exact same
coverage the same towers the same bars
but it cost you half
no contract no excessive fees you can
save a lot of money and you can do
better things with that money then hand
it over to one of these big cell phone
companies right now
enjoy unlimited talk text two gigs of
data all for just 20 bucks a month the
average person is saving 400
a year on their wireless bill so grab
your mobile phone dial pound 250 and say
ben shapiro when you do you save 250
bucks off any iphone
including the new iphone se again that
is pound two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro that's pure talk
usa simply smarter wireless
and save 250 bucks off any iphone
including that new iphone
se when you dial pound 250 say ben
shapiro and get started with pure talk
usa great way to save money okay so
before we begin i just want to note that
it is in fact the 233rd
birthday of the constitution of the
united states on this day 233 years ago
the signatories of the constitution in
got together they signed the document it
is an incredible document and i want to
take just a brief moment
and read to you from my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps on
the constitution because it's important
to recognize
why the constitution is important so
abraham lincoln
suggested that the constitution was a
frame of silver a picture of silver
around an apple of gold the apple of
gold being the declaration of
independence meaning we have certain
fundamental philosophies
in the united states this philosophy of
the declaration of independence and it
was protected
by a system that was designed to ensure
that the philosophy was enacted here's
how i talk about it
in my book the philosophy of the united
states rests on three basic principles
first the reality of natural rights
which pre-exists government inalienable
and precious
second the equality of all human beings
before the law and in their rights
and finally the belief that government
exists only to protect natural rights
and to enforce equality before the law
american philosophy believes these
propositions are self-evident
in the words of the declaration of
independence the founders attempted to
implement american philosophy
through a unique set of institutions the
constitution of the united states was a
compromised document designed to
enshrine american philosophy
via limited government system that
constitutional systems enumerated powers
balanced the necessity for action
embodied in the in the legislative power
with the necessity to avoid tyranny
the constitutional systems checks
effectively balanced the requirement of
an executive
powerful enough to respond to threats
and enforce law with the requirements to
avoid despotism embodied in checks and
balances
the constitutional system's federalism
was constructed to frustrate national
schemes to subsume the character of
local
communities while simultaneously
preventing those local communities from
becoming autocracies
okay so to put that in maybe even
simpler english
there are basically three things that
the constitution was designed to do
one was to enumerate powers the
government is only given a certain
number of enumerated powers the
constitution
lists them off and this was that the
government did not have the ability to
infringe upon
your core rights as a human being second
the constitutional system
put in place these checks and balances
between the various branches of the
federal government
so that you didn't have an executive
branch that overran all of its
boundaries or a legislative branch that
overran all of its boundaries or
judiciary that overran all of its
boundaries again the idea was that
ambition was supposed to counteract
ambition and in doing so
your rights as an american would be
protected and finally the constitution
set up a federalist system
a federalist system that allows the
federal government to do things that
need to be done
but also prevents the federal government
from infringing on the local character
of communities and at the same time
prevents local communities from
infringing on the core human rights of
the citizens inside
those local communities that's what the
constitution was designed to do
and over time as it was amended
increasingly did
it is a document well worth celebrating
and when you see so many people in the
united states today
who essentially see the constitution as
a vestige of a dead past oh it's this
document that means nothing anymore
understand there's a long history to
that kind of thinking going all the way
back to the progressives at the
beginning of the 20th century
and the worst president in american
history woodrow wilson this view of the
constitution
as a barrier to the things we want to do
the constitution is a barrier
to a government becoming so powerful
that it can cram down on you
anything including violations of your
rights in the name of pure
majoritarianism
in the name of the mob in the name of
your local community
without any sort of federal intervention
and there was a balancing act that was
attempting to be done
by the founding fathers and they
achieved it in incredible fashion the
constitution is unbelievable
unbelievably durable it's one of the
reasons why you see so many folks on the
left today and they declare donald trump
of fascists and you look at what trump
actually does and you say how
like how name you the fascist thing that
trump is doing even if you thought he
had authoritarian tendencies
the document has been so robust that it
has prevented
that from happening even if you're on
the left and the same thing is true on
the right barack obama i think had
extraordinarily authoritarian tendencies
it's why he talked about a pen and a
phone
that's why he talked about bending law
pretty routinely it's why he militarized
parts of his own government the irs for
example but the constitution is robust
enough
to even hem in the the most
authoritarian characters who take up the
presidency now that doesn't mean that we
don't need to do a better job of
electing our public leaders what it does
mean
is that we ought to recognize that the
constitution systems those checks and
balances are crucial
and in a time when exactly those things
are coming under fire
it is important to remember why they are
important right now
we have ascendant wings and maybe both
parties that see
the fundamentals of the constitution as
a threat to the future of the country
who believe that enumerated powers
prevent the government from doing
what it is supposed to do why can't we
just do bigger things why can't we just
move beyond these enumerated powers i
mean these people lived 230 years ago
the reason that the constitution is
still relevant is because human nature
has not changed in the last 233 years
the reason the declaration is still
relevant is because human nature has not
changed
since the declaration of independence in
but there are people who want to
overthrow these fundamental principles
right they believe
that enumerated powers are a problem
because they prevent the government from
doing the things we
want to do and this is what you see from
democrats who say for example
that the federal government should be
able to cram down on you a health care
mandate or the federal government should
be able to cram down on you
federal education mandates or all this
stuff is beyond the scope of what the
federal government was designed to do
you see the same thing in the way that
members of both parties seem to dislike
checks and balances right that they
believe that the federal government
ought to have no checks and balances
right now you're seeing this mostly from
the democrats who want to get rid of the
filibuster who say that the senate
itself
is constituted undemocratically which by
the way is the point
it is the point is that states were
supposed to be able to check each other
because they were independent bodies
before the foundation of the united
states
the checks and balances were part of the
system they were designed to create
gridlock when you see people
bemoaning gridlock at the federal level
gridlock was part of the system
it was designed for gridlock but people
don't like gridlock
except if their rights are being
violated and when it comes to federalism
you see the democrats taking the
position that states should be
either summarily be overrun by the
federal government or
if they're red states and if they're
blue states they should be left to their
own devices by the federal government
as soon as you believe that the
institutions of the constitution are no
longer important
you have left behind the philosophy that
believes the declaration is important
because
all of those mechanisms were designed to
protect that core of gold that
philosophy
that suggests that all men are created
equal endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable rights
alrighty so just thought that i'd sound
off a little bit on constitution day
because this is
one of our great forgotten holidays
constitution day september 17th alright
meanwhile we are seeing
facebook beginning to involve itself in
censorship to an extraordinary degree
there there's
a couple of stories that that are coming
out of facebook that are truly
disturbing
and really it has more to do with the
fact checkers that facebook has chosen
to rely upon facebook itself they
shouldn't have set up the system this
way
but the fact that facebook set up the
system so that left-wing fact-checkers
could skew the system
is really a horrible move and
unjustifiable
i'll explain in just one second these
are some pretty wild stories and how
social media
can really screw with the political
narrative on the basis of
the left really lying the fact checkers
are just so many of these factors are
just liars
open liars we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about
a simple fact and that is you don't
actually want to go to the post office
right now
and maybe ever in fact you would love
savings by not going to the post office
not only can you save time
not only can you save money but you can
save your peace of mind and not stand in
line at the post office by going to
stamps.com
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits of stamps.com in
recent months they've been able to keep
their businesses running
avoid the crowds at the post office all
from their own computers with stamps.com
you can print postage on demand and
avoid going to the post office
and you'll save money with discounted
rates you cannot even get at the post
office
stamps.com offers ups services too with
discounts up to 62
no residential surcharges here at daily
wire we've used stamps.com
since 2017. no more wasting our time
stamps.com brings all the mailing and
shipping services you need
directly to your computer in the comfort
of your home or office whether you're a
small business sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products or
you're just working from home you need
to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class email anywhere you
want to send it
then when it's ready just leave it for
the mail carrier schedule a pickup or
drop it in a mailbox
it is indeed that simple right now my
listeners get a special offer ooh
it includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale
no long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
shapiro that is stamps.com enter shapiro
again stamps.com
enter shapiro go check them out right
now okay so
there's been a lot of talk in the recent
past about social media and it's
crackdown on the flow of information and
i have defended some of these companies
and i have gone after some of these
companies of all the social media
companies i've defended facebook the
most because frankly it would be
hypocritical
for me not to considering that facebook
has been a benefit to my company
considering we do tremendous traffic on
facebook but that doesn't mean that the
system that facebook has set up for fact
checking is not unbelievably skewed and
actually
quite dangerous i'll give you two
examples today so facebook set up this
system
the system is that if you get dinged by
one of their designated fact checkers
they will censor your ad right they will
remove your ad
well what happens if the fact checkers
that were designated
are left wing so politifact is not a
fact checker politifact is a left-wing
outlet
it is like a media matters left-wing
outlet outlet it is designed
to fact-check implications politifacts
will do these fact checks where they
will fully admit right in the body of
the article
that what they are fact-checking is not
factually false they'll just say that we
don't like the implication therefore we
rate it mostly false
politifact is an overtly political
outlet the fact that they masquerade as
an objective fact checker is a joke this
has been true for
literally years i remember several years
back i cut a video in which all i did
was just read statistics from pew global
pew global polling on the feelings of
muslims globally
about a wide variety of controversial
issues ranging from support to terrorism
to support for honor killings and all
this i read all of this
that was the entire video the entire
video was just noting what percentage of
muslims in like afghanistan believed in
honor killing and then saying this seems
like an extreme belief
that was the entire video politifact
rated the video false
because they said that my standards for
extremism were not objective standards
of extremism which is not in fact a
false rating that is just them saying
they disagree with my definitions
okay that is that's that's called a
political argument politifact does this
stuff
all the time all the time and the fact
that facebook decided to use politifact
as one of its trusted fact checkers
leads to perverse results like this and
they're now two separate ads
that have been taken down after being
declared quasi-false by facebook
so the first ad came from the america
first pack this is one of donald trump's
super pacs
so it's not related to the trump
campaign a super pac operates
independently of the campaigns this is
not trump himself this is the america
first pack it's run by linda mcmahon
who used to be the head of his small
business administration okay so the
the super pac ran this ad as you are
about to hear the ad is completely
accurate
there's nothing wrong with this ad the
ad makes a simple claim joe biden is
going to raise your taxes
that's the entire claim politifact rated
the ad mostly false it was removed from
facebook on the basis of politifact
bullcrap fact check so here is this ad
sometimes politicians accidentally tell
the truth
guess what if you elect me i'm not gonna
have you your taxes are gonna be raised
not cut
and it's true the new york times says
biden's tax increases are more than
double hillary clinton's plan even the
tax policy center admits
taxes would increase on all income
groups if you elect me i could have you
your taxes are going to be raised not
cut
big tax increases crushing our recovery
it could go higher
america first action is responsible for
the content of this advertising there's
not a single word of that that is false
in fact
the the ad itself cites its sources
right throughout the ad
so politifact they had launched august
4th it was then slapped with a mostly
false rating
by politifact and then it was blocked by
facebook like full-on blocked by
facebook
again the ad directly quotes biden
saying if you elect me your taxes are
going to be raised
not cut so what exactly how exactly did
politifact rationalize its mostly false
rating
they accused the pack this according to
john beckley editor-in-chief of daily
wire
of not giving the audience of for this
30-second spot enough context
and giving the wrong impression about
what biden meant so it's a context
check okay nothing in there is actually
false it is a
they say that it is lacking context
which normally we would call like the
basis for a political discussion or
argument right if you cite to me a fact
and i say listen here's what you're
missing you're missing this particular
context
it doesn't mean that what you are saying
is overtly false it means that i believe
that you are not placing it in the
proper context right that's how
a lot of political conversations go but
politifact rated it mostly false
so here is how their stupid fact check
begins they say a new ad from pro-trump
super pac uses out-of-context footage of
joe biden
to claim that the former vice president
wants to raise taxes for americans
across the board
while the america first action ad
presents that remark out of context
some tax experts estimate that biden's
plan would mean higher taxes on average
for all income groups but those
increases would be relatively small for
all but the biggest earners
so in other words they say that while
it's true that biden is going to
increase taxes for everyone
he's mostly going to increase taxes for
rich people therefore the ad is mostly
false that's insane
so you're admitting that the ad is true
you just
agree with joe biden's policy and so
you're going to declare the ad mostly
false
politifact specifically cites a biden
campaign official as supposed
evidence of the democrats intent the
full exchange shows that biden was
saying his plan would raise taxes for
people who in the words
in his words quote benefited from the
gop's tax cuts and job act
of 2017. a biden campaign official said
his point was that the wealthy not all
americans would not benefit
from his plan but here's the thing
everybody benefited from the tax cuts
and jobs act of 2017 because everybody
received a tax cut
so that that's a that's a bull crap fact
check it's just not true
the fact check goes on to make a
similarly flimsy case against the adds
inclusion of biden warning his tax
increases could go higher
the supposed evidence of this being
quote unquote mostly false is the
following full quote from biden quote
we should charge people the same tax for
their capital gains as their tax rate is
and i think we should raise the tax rate
back to you for example i take it back
to where it was before it was reduced
it could go higher that's literally him
saying he's going to increase taxes
this ad is not false so politifact
declared it mostly false based on the
fact that they actually agree with joe
biden's policy
that isn't even the worst case of
facebook or moving something based on a
bullcrap politif
fact check okay the worst case is there
is a group
there's a there's another group that is
called the americans principles project
the american principles project ran an
ad in michigan
okay this ad in michigan targeted the
governor of michigan
because the governor of michigan backs
the so-called equality act
and the so-called equality act
essentially abolishes the ability
of biological women to compete against
only biological women in sports
right the the equality act suggests that
if you're a man and you say that you're
a woman you should now be able to
compete with women in sports
right transgender women should be able
to compete with actual biological women
in sports which of course destroys
women's sports because now you have
biological males competing with
biological females
in a second i'm going to show you this
ad then i'm going to tell you what the
politifact
fact check said this ad was taken down
from facebook
this is unconscionable stuff if facebook
is removing
ads and content based on the biased
insanity of politifact facebook needs to
feel the heat on that
now i've been a great advocate of not
regulating these social media companies
because i don't want the government
sitting above the social media companies
and determining exactly what can and
cannot be put on there because i don't
want elizabeth warren in charge of that
i don't want the democrats appointing a
majority of the fcc and then cramming
down
their perspective on what should be
online on these various social media
companies i'd rather let a thousand
flowers bloom makes it very difficult
for me to make that case
when companies like facebook that
control huge flows of information
allow this sort of nonsense to happen
where they explicitly outsource
their judgment to politifact at that
point they're just a left-wing source
nascar rating is an objective source
which which is not acceptable
under any circumstances we'll get to
that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that sleep is
pretty darn important these days so my
kid woke me up last night my baby
love her she's adorable she woke me up
last night from four to five a.m
it was no fun but there was good news
when i was in bed
and she was not waking me up i was
sleeping like a baby why
because of my pillow okay my pillow this
stuff is everything they make is just
incredible
so my wife and i we have a couple of my
pillows they are just
most comfortable pillows ever truly
truly amazing
stuff and they don't just do pillows
they also do sheets they do all sorts of
bedding it's really top-notch
mike lindell is the inventor of my
pillow mike's latest deal is on his giza
dreams sheets they're made from the
world's best cotton
giza cotton they're ultra soft they're
breathable they're extremely durable
right now the giza dream sheets are at a
two for on low price
they're a twofer plus free shipping with
promo code daily wire
all of my pillow products come with a
60-day money-back guarantee
go to mypillow.com click on the radio
listener square to check out
the two for one low price on the giza
dream sheets plus free shipping
there are also deep discounts on all the
other my pillow products as well
obviously you've heard about my pillow
other places i'm here to testify
everything you've heard about the
quality of their product is absolutely
true it is absolutely great
this stuff is just terrific there's a
reason the company is so successful
enter promo code dailywire or call
1148 800-651-1148 800 651 1148
for these excellent excellent specials
go check out mypillow.com right now
click on that radio listener square and
check out the two for one low price on
the giza dreams sheets plus free
shipping
go check out my pillow this is solid
stuff you're gonna get better sleep
quality with it
okay so here is the other ad that was
run again there is nothing
that is inaccurate about this ad nothing
it was pulled down because politifact a
biased source is used in the algorithm
for facebook
facebook should change its algorithm
there's no doubt about it anything they
should
honestly they should bar politifact from
being part of the program for gaming the
system
i think facebook's core assumption is
that politifact was going to act like a
fact checker not like an arm of the
democratic party but apparently that
assumption was incorrect it should never
have been made i mean politifact has
always been an arm of the democratic
party in any case
here is the here's the ad that was
banned all female athletes want
is a fair shot at competition at a
scholarship
at a title at victory but what if that
shot was taken away by a competitor who
claims to be a girl
but was born a boy senator gary peters
and joe biden support legislation
that would destroy girls sports they
call it
equality really that's not fair
not fair at all vote against gary peters
and joe biden
they are too extreme for michigan okay
that's senator gary peters the ad is
against it there's
everything about that is true every
single word about that ad is true
it is of course true i mean this has
become the basis for lawsuits in places
like connecticut where transgender
athletes are competing against
biological women and they are destroying
them
because it turns out that if you grow up
as a boy you have a different
physiological structure than growing up
as a girl of course of course i know
biology
this stuff's super controversial so the
science is real crowd on the democratic
side okay so here's politifact fact
check that caused facebook to take this
down
quote their specific criticism is that
allowing transgender girls and women to
compete on the basis of their gender
identity would create an uneven playing
field for student athletes
and ultimately end girls and women's
sports quote
that's a prediction we can't fact-check
so they overtly say they can't
fact-check the pres
the position it doesn't matter because
they say that the ad
is lacking context it's missing context
facebook removed it
so politifact politifact says we can't
fact-check the ad
and facebook's response is okay we'll
take it down okay this is getting to be
quite ugly
and it's not just facebook obviously
we're seeing this on youtube as well
a little bit earlier this week dr scott
atlas who's been a guest on this program
and dr atlas had some videos on youtube
talking about covid
atlas has been a lockdown skeptic since
the earliest days
and he has claimed repeatedly
that for example the this thing has
differential diagnoses based on whether
you're elderly or whether you are
younger
he has said that there's not a lot of
evidence that children are passing this
with great frequency for example it was
a video of that that was taken so
youtube took down that video
saying that it did not meet with the
who's
information okay well if if you had had
to abide by the what the who
says is true standard then saying in
february that this thing was airborne
would have not would have conflicted
with the who if you had said
in late february hey we should all mask
up that would have conflicted with the
whole
using the who as the scientific gold
standard then removing videos that
conflict with the who
which was a chinese-run operation
essentially in the early days of covet
is crazy but that's exactly what youtube
did youtube put out a statement to the
wall street journal saying it removed
the atlas interview for quote
falsely stating that a certain age group
cannot transmit the virus
the company was apparently referring to
dr atlas's remark amid a discussion
about school reopening that children
do not even transmit the disease that
seems to have been an exaggeration for
emphasis dr atlas corrected himself in
the next answer
saying transmission by children is quote
not impossible but it's less likely
that is 100 true so what they are now
doing on youtube
is they are acting as though everything
that you say spontaneously is a term
paper
so if i if i exaggerate for emphasis
which everybody
does rhetorically speaking every single
day everybody
if you speak off the cuff you're likely
to be banned by youtube because you
didn't footnote everything in precisely
the way that youtube wanted you get the
same thing on facebook
by the way my co-host another host over
here at the daily wire michael moles
he's been dinged by facebook because he
said for rhetorical emphasis that there
was quote no evidence that masks work he
then followed up by suggesting that the
swedish health officials and the
norwegian health officials
had basically said that there's not a
lot of evidence that it works okay so he
emphasized and he overemphasized and he
exaggerated for emphasis
and facebook dinged him right this is
the kind of stuff where it only works on
one side by the way
if you are a democrat and you say that
donald trump is removing mailboxes from
the streets to prevent mail-in voting so
to steal the election they won't remove
any of that crap
any of it here was scott atlas on tucker
carlson last night saying this is absurd
i think this sort of move to censor
people like me
and others i'm not just talking about
myself really has precipitated a
backlash here we saw it in the media now
lots of things have been written
uh talking about what i've said and how
outrageous it is that that stuff was
censored or even uh you know an interest
by some of my
former colleagues and censoring me by
public shaming or cancellation
you know these kinds of things are
really destructive and harmful
not only is it wrong in terms of the
truth it's also instilling
fear into the public okay so it it's
crazy i mean you you now have a complete
grip on the flow of information another
example so last night
tucker hosted on his show a chinese
scientist this chinese scientist
has claimed that the virus was produced
in woohen lab and then released
and now i don't know whether that's true
or not you don't know that's true or not
youtube doesn't know whether it's true
or not
nobody knows whether it's true or not it
doesn't matter youtube took down the
video
and so did facebook by the way here's
tucker carlson talking about that last
night
but it's clear that dr liman yang is a
serious person she is making a very
serious claim
so within a few hours of her interview
last night a video of the segment
reached 1.3 million people on facebook
and why wouldn't it the chronovirus
pandemic has touched the life of
every american and justifiably people
want to know
where it came from but facebook still
doesn't want you to know that
so facebook suppressed the video
presumably on behalf of the chinese
government
facebook executives made it harder for
users to watch our segment
those who found the video had to
navigate a warning the interview quote
repeats information about covid19 that
independent fact checkers
say is false okay this standard is the
problem okay which independent fact
checkers who are these independent fact
checkers and why should we trust them
okay you have to fact check the fact
checkers because not all fact checkers
are created equals we have seen they
will overtly rate false
claims that are clearly true these two
separate ads just in the last week that
have been removed that are overtly true
and that the fact checker itself
admits are basically true this is
dangerous stuff
it is and if these companies wish to
remain independent
and they don't want everybody just
rushing to the government for a solution
which
again i am against i don't think the
government should step in in these cases
overall
it's gonna be real difficult for the
government not to step in
at the behest of people who believe that
their rights are being violated by
social media companies
that are at the very least
quasi-fraudulently claiming
to be open and objective participants in
a platform rather than
in in some sort of publication and i'm
against that sort of legislation
but you got to make it easier for me
guys you can't do this you can't make
politifact your outsourced fact checker
and then claim that you are merely a
platform not a publication politifact is
a publication and if you are just doing
their bidding you become a publication
as well
okay this is dangerous stuff okay in
just a second
we are going to be getting to all of the
the latest on kovid because there are
some crazy stories today
out on covid and the handling of covet
particularly in blue areas
first let us talk about the fact that
you need to hire better people you do
i mean i need to hire better people hell
we're moving to nashville we're looking
to hire a lot of people
and that means that we are using a zip
recruiter zip recruiter sends your job
to over 100 of the web's leading job
sites but they don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter will scan thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience
and then actively invite them to apply
to your job zip recruiter makes hiring
efficient and effective with features
like screening questions to filter
candidates and an all-in-one dashboard
where you can review
and rate your candidates zip recruiter
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candid
within the very first day like we have a
lot of fantastic
employees here at the daily wire we do
one of those fantastic employees is
producer colton producer colton
is an excellent employee except when he
is just dead set
on particular guests who don't really
have much to do with the show but he's
like super obsessed with the guests but
wants to make sure that this guest gets
like three hours on the program
at that point i started thinking hmm zip
recruiter zip recruiter try it for free
my listeners can go to zippercrew.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e-z
recruiter.com dailywire zippercareer is
indeed the smartest way to hire go check
them out right now
ziprecruiter.com dailywire alrighty so
some news on kovit so it is incredible
that the treatment of covid people keep
screaming from the rooftops
follow the science this is the democrat
follow the science okay but they don't
actually follow the science
in fact they don't care about the
science this has become overtly
political it's been overtly political
for months now
and yet the democrats keep claiming that
they're following the science and i'm
just wondering
how now i've been very critical of much
that president trump has done
with regard to with regards or at least
said with regard to covet i think when
it comes to what he's done
i'm not sure that he had tons of choices
on what he's done it seems like
everybody has failed pretty much
everywhere
because there aren't great policies when
it comes to a global pandemic that seems
to basically stick around
until it burns its way through
communities the basic logic of covet is
that it burns through communities all he
can do is shield the sick and the
vulnerable
the elderly and then it just passes
through and then it's done right this is
the lesson from sweden where they never
shut down and their big failure was they
didn't protect the sick and vulnerable
at the very beginning if they had
sweden would be widely perceived to be
what it is
a model for how to handle this thing
everybody in europe is now experiencing
the so-called second wave it is not a
second wave
it is a continuation of the first wave
it's just that when you lock down
all you did was delay the inevitable
which is the spread of this thing
through communities now
maybe that's a good thing right delaying
it allowed for better therapeutic
procedures it allowed for hospitals to
figure out how to treat this thing
better
the death in hospitals rates is down
dramatically right florida
and georgia and texas and arizona they
all got waves those waves happened a lot
later than new jersey new york
and that meant that they weren't having
people lie in their back with
ventilators they're flipping people on
their stomachs they were giving them
rem to severe they were giving them
steroidal injections they had better
treatments for this thing so the death
rates were much much lower that's why
when people say
well florida georgia arizona texas look
how badly they handled it
okay the curves are not even comparable
in terms of death
right new york new jersey connecticut
massachusetts
their curves are enormous in terms of
death because this thing hit early and
hospitals didn't know how to handle it
some of that is cuomo's fault some of
it's not cuomo's fault right some of it
is just if it hit you early
then there wasn't much you could do but
lockdowns are not the solution
particularly not endless lockdowns it
doesn't matter democrats are pursuing
endless lockdowns
today new york city announced that
schools will not physically reopen for
all students on monday
instead the city is doing a phased-in
reopening by grade level through the
next few weeks
this is the second time bill de blasio
garbage commie mayor of new york
has delayed in-person classes three days
before the start of the school year they
announced this
so parents had made their plans they'd
figure out what to do and by the way
online schooling is failing everywhere
it's tried heavy
heavy percentages like up to half maybe
more than half in certain school
districts of kids
are not even logging on to go to zoom
school because
honestly you can't keep kids
concentrating in regular school you
think you're going to plunk them down in
front of a boring screen like my
daughter
is doing some zoom school right now as
we prepare for our move and
she is a kid with an extraordinary
attention span i mean she you know she's
brilliant
she's going into first grade she reads
at fourth grade it doesn't matter she's
still easily distracted because she's
literally sitting there
looking at a screen where the teacher's
walking around the classroom dealing
with
it's kind of half in class half zoom
school and that that's a pro this stuff
does not work okay zoom school is not
good
it is not good the only way that it
works is if basically you're
homeschooling your kid and you're just
using the zoom as a supplement that is
the only way that it works
and parents have built their lives
around this stuff parents still have to
work
parents still have to have lives i mean
school is about a couple of things yes
it's outsourcing the education but it's
also outsourcing the daycare
everybody understands what school is
bill de blasio three days before the
start of school canceled it in new york
city
there is no curve in new york city
because everybody died in new york city
it burned through it burned through new
york city the transmission rate in new
york city is
well below one percent it's extremely
low the number of positive tests
in manhattan is nearly zero the number
of deaths in manhattan is zero
and yet they're still not reopening the
schools which again are not a main
vector of transmission anywhere in the
world they are not there is no evidence
i mean
i mean this seriously there is no
evidence that schools are main
vectors of transmission that does not
mean
culvert can't be transmitted at a school
it does mean that the chief vectors of
transmission
so far as we have seen are not in
schools and this is true across europe
it's true pretty much everywhere which
is why you're having to see
all of these idiotic headlines declaring
teachers are getting covered and then
you read the story and it turns out the
teacher got covered three weeks before
school reopened
there's an ap story that cited this
right that said oh look at look at these
three teachers they died from covet
all three of them had gotten covered
from places that were not in school
i'm reading you the stats from manhattan
here are the stats from manhattan as of
yesterday this is worldometers.info
which is i believe the johns hopkins
university
information manhattan which is a
a population of 1.6 million is manhattan
county
you ready for this here's how many
positive cova tests they had yesterday
positive coveted tests yesterday 63
in a county of 1.6 million people how
many new deaths did they have yesterday
zero zero
yesterday and bill de blasio is shutting
down all of the schools
they're not physically reopening he says
he spoke for hours yesterday with the
head of the principals and teachers
union who said schools are not ready to
reopen they've been saying this for many
weeks
the mayor said the information flow
about exactly what was needed
about exactly what was needed where it
needed to be improved
okay so he says that um many outer
borough families are pragmatic and
understand the realities of life he said
i feel for any parent that has to make
new arrangements
i know people will do what they have to
do he declines to apologize to new york
city families for the last minute change
this is anti-scientific nonsense it is
anti-scientific crap
bill de blasio is a garbage garbage
mayor my goodness
he is a garbage mayor wild
okay and and what we are also seeing is
that the the party of science
is covering up the science in many cases
so we've been hearing from the media
over and over and over again
that the real bad guy in all of this of
course is is ron desantis in florida
now let's be clear the dashboard for
florida when it comes to covet info
is maybe the most transparent dashboard
anywhere in the country they've been
extremely transparent about their
information
in florida you know they weren't quite
so forthcoming about their information
in the dailywire's new home city of
nashville according to fox17.com
this is an insane story the coronaviru
the coronavirus cases on lower broadway
may have been so low that the mayor's
office and metro health department
decided to keep it secret
okay so the claim from the left is that
republican governors and mayors they've
been covering up deaths in cases
there's not evidence of this there is
now evidence that in nashville
the mayor's office was covering up the
fact that bars and restaurants were not
vectors of transmission
so that they could justify shutting down
the bars and restaurants they literally
put thousands of people out of work
in order to and then covered up the data
suggesting it was unnecessary
this is an insane story emails between
the mayor's senior advisor and the
health department reveal only a partial
picture but what they reveal is
disturbing
the discussion involves the low number
of coronavirus cases emerging from bars
and restaurants
and how to handle that and most
disturbingly how to keep it from the
public
on june 30th contact tracing was given a
small view of coronavirus clusters
construction and nursing homes were
found to be causing problems with more
than a thousand cases traced to each
category
which makes sense i mean we know that
nursing homes are our chief factor we
also know
that contract workers who are working in
close proximity with each other
tend to spread it bars and restaurants
reported just
22 cases leslie waller from the health
department asked this isn't going to be
publicly released right just info for
the mayor's office
correct not for public consumption
writes senior adviser benjamin eagles
a month later the health department was
asked point blank about the rumor there
were only 80 cases in all of nashville
traced to bars and restaurants reporter
nate rao asked
the figure you gave of more than 80 does
lead to a natural question
if there have been over 20 000 positive
cases of kova 19
in davidson and only 80 or so are traced
to restaurants and bars doesn't that
mean restaurants and bars aren't a very
big problem
health department official brian todd
asked five health department officials
please advise how you recommend i
respond the name at the top of the
response is clipped
but here is the answer quote my two
cents we have certainly refused to give
counts
per bar because those numbers are low
per site we could still release the
total though
and then the response to the over 80
could be that because the number is
increasing all the time and we don't
want to say a specific number
neither the health department nor the
mayor's office would confirm the
authenticity of the emails but a council
member named steve glover had a metro
staff attorney inquire here was the
official answer
i was able to get verifications from the
mayor's office and the department of
health
these emails are real glover says
they're fabricating information
they've blown their entire credibility
it's gone i don't trust a thing they say
going forward
nothing he says we raised taxes 34
percent we put hundreds
of hundreds literally thousands of
people out of work that are now worried
about losing their homes their
apartments and we did it on bogus data
that should be illegal
yes it damn well should be it damn well
should be you want to build trust with
the public
you know what you don't do lie to them
about the vectors of transmission
schools are not main vectors of
transmission
okay we don't know about bars and
restaurants broadly speaking what we do
know is that in nashville they covered
up whatever data they did have
how are you supposed to trust public
officials when they're overtly lying to
you
that's crazy and then these same people
will be like the science says lockdowns
are necessary the science the science
and then the same people tried out
andrew cuomo
at the dnc to proclaim that he did a
wonderful job
in in coffin covered new york
incredible and we'll get to more of the
sciences real gang on covet 19 in just a
second because joe biden gave a big
speech about science
being real science being real we'll get
to that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that you need to protect
your online data you do
now there's this stuff out there it's
called ransomware if you've never been
hit by it
it's absolutely terrible right somebody
will actually hack your computer
and then they will hold ransom at your
files until you pay the money
and people are coming up with new ways
to grab your information and then
blackmail you
every single day or steal your
information just use it this is why you
need pcmatic it's a next-generation
anti-virus designed to stop
modern threats like ransomware
independent testing from av test just
named pcmatic a top performer in the
cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019.
only pcmatic has american research
development and support pcmatic's
competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates pcmatic will block annoying
and malicious ads for hassle-free web
browsing it makes your computers faster
and more reliable even after years of
use
pcmatic protects windows computers
including xp vista windows 7 8 and 10
windows servers max macbooks and android
phones and tablets pcmatic it's just 50
bucks for five devices for one year with
a full
30 day money back guarantee if you act
now pcmatic has offered my listeners a
free month of security protection with
the purchase of an annual license
protecting your information this is
really not something you should put at
risk to access
this offer go to pcmatic.com again
world's class security that keeps your
computer running great and ain't gonna
cost you a fortune
pcmatic.com then okay
more on covet 19 and the science is real
we'll party we'll get to that in just
one second
first you may have heard the big news we
are trading crappy governors for happy
southerners
nanny state for real estate and high
taxes for hot chicken
we're moving the daily wire to nashville
and we are very excited about it
that is why right now we are practicing
a little southern hospitality gang
by offering 15 off select memberships
using
code nashville tonight michael moles and
matt walsh will be answering your
questions about the move on all access
live starting at 4 pm pacific time
throughout the move i will be hopping on
you'll be getting the behind-the-scenes
looks
on our all-access episodes join now we
would love to have you join these
conversations
see all y'all in nashville see i know
that y'all is singular and all y'all is
plural after you finish watching that
tonight
i'm excited to join adam carolla dennis
prager dave rubin and others for hashtag
cancelcon
an important conversation on cancel
culture and the constitution
this special live stream is brought to
you by our friends at yaf and the film
those safe spaces will begin at 8 pm
eastern 5 pm pacific
on the daily wire youtube channel and
facebook page that is hashtag cancelcon
live tonight at 8pm eastern 5pm pacific
at dailywear youtube and facebook you
don't want to miss it
lastly september 28th you got to know
this okay this is important
all of my show's content is moving to my
channel mine
youtube.com ben shapiro the link is in
the description below do not neglect to
do this or you're going to miss my show
there will still be content on the daily
wire channel
but my daily show will be on my channel
we are making room for some new
exclusive content on daily wire more on
that later
i'm also making a lot of new content you
can only find on my magical channel so
subscribe to youtube.com ben shapiro
ring the bell to make sure you never
miss out on a new video you are watching
or listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so joe biden the party of
science so yesterday he gives a speech
about vaccines
and in the middle of the speech he
basically says i like vaccines and i
like science but i don't like trump
and i don't like trump and that means
that i i'm not going to trust a vaccine
but maybe i will trust a vaccine but
maybe i won't and then he fell asleep
because that's what he does in the
middle of his speeches the harris biden
campaign moving forward with alacrity
here was joe biden yesterday
so let me be clear i trust vaccines
i trust scientists but i don't
trust donald trump at this moment the
american people can't either
um so donald trump is not actually
running the vaccine development
nor is he forcing procedural changes at
the fda
this is actually kind of dangerous what
we have seen in polls is that more and
more americans are refusing to take the
vaccine even if it's developed
so if you actually want this thing to
come to an end what you really need is
vulnerable americans to take the vaccine
i don't know that you need children to
take the vaccine the reason i say that
is because if kids get it
who cares right kids are not dying from
this period end of story the number of
kids who have died from this is in low
double digits
in a country of 330 million people okay
but if you are elderly if you're at risk
if you have a preexisting condition or
you have diabetes or something then
getting the vaccine is pretty damned
important
and you would like for people who are
generally healthy to also get the
vaccine so they don't become
vectors of transmission because adults
do transmit this to adults the evidence
that kids don't transmit it quite as
much
or in as severe numbers as adults okay
so what you don't want to do is
undermine the vaccine party of science
should understand this
after all science is real they even put
it on their stupid lawn signs
okay except that now you have joe biden
openly questioning whether
if a vaccine is developed under the
trump administration people should take
it
and the polls are reflecting this in
early may most americans 55 percent said
they would get vaccinated for covenant
19 if and when a vaccine becomes
available
now four months later less than
one-third of americans 32
say they plan to get vaccinated that is
a 23-point decline
that is being overtly pushed by the
democratic party and the members of the
media
the sciences real party is anti-vaccine
if trump develops a vaccine because it
might be good for trump
this is just the denial of reality this
is a common part of the denial of
reality
for so many members of the democratic
party if something good happens and
trump is president it wasn't good
that's the way the thinking goes
seriously that that is
the newer skeptics tend to be democrats
who could have predicted this according
to yahoo news and yougov
they've consistently found a hardline
group of anti-vaxxers who say they will
not get vaccinated no matter what
is about 20 percent of the population
they're generally concentrated more on
the right but
while the number of republicans who say
they would get vaccinated has declined
14 points from may
from 47 to 33 the corresponding number
of democrats
has plummeted twice as much from 70 to
over the same period of time so the
science i am very pro vaccination
the science is real party is undermining
american faith
in vaccines again because
it might redown to trump's benefit if
people actually were to take the vaccine
and so you have joe biden overtly saying
well i like vaccines and i like science
but i don't like donald
trump what does that have to do with
anything if vaccines were developed
under barack obama i would take them
like what what the hell are we talking
about here
i don't think that barack obama would
deliberately put out i really just like
barack obama i don't think
barack obama would deliberately put out
a faulty vaccine to kill people what the
hell are you talking about here
meanwhile what we are learning from the
sciences real party is that vaccines are
bad or questionable if developed under
trump but masks are very good
now again the evidence on masks is mixed
it is mixed
there are studies that suggest that
masks are useful if particularly you're
in populated areas
and they are mostly useful not to you
they're useful for for protecting other
people so you sneeze you're wearing a
mask instead of it
going everywhere now it just goes
emotionally into the mask it gets
outside the mask a little bit but mostly
it goes into the mask this is why i have
long been a proponent of if you are in a
crowded area
or in an area where people are
vulnerable or elderly you should wear a
mask
my parents when they come over to my
house they wear masks like i'm a
i'm a mask proponent but to pretend that
there is no mixed evidence on this is
very silly the netherlands
sweden all of the scandinavian countries
do not mess up
the masking rate in scandinavia is below
10 the masking rate in italy is close to
90 percent
italy got wamped the netherlands did not
not nearly in the same numbers
okay so the the evidence is mixed right
we can say that like you can be pro mask
and also acknowledge that the evidence
is mixed as to the efficacy
of mass adoption of mass particularly if
people are not wearing it properly like
my wife
when she was in medical schools have
said they actually had full courses they
had like a full seminar on how to
properly don ppe personal protective
equipment
if you put on the mask wrong it's a
problem if you put the mask below your
nose
that is a problem you see all these
videos of people in crowds
and people are cheering them for wearing
the mask and they've got the mask below
the nose that's not doing anything
you breathe through your nose idiots if
you actually want the mask to work you
got to put it up above your nose
now you see people who are i still see
tons of people wearing neck gaiters
there's a study from the cdc that came
out and said neck gaitors are worse than
nothing
right because neck gaitors actually
encourage people to
violate social distancing and they don't
they actually aerosolize stuff better
because
if you sneeze into a neck gator then
actually it explodes out
okay so but half the population still
wearing that gators
so all of this is to say that when
people keep talking about masks as
opposed to a vaccine
the the answer is both and right we want
a vaccine and also if you're in a
crowded area you should wear a mask
but instead you got joe biden being like
i don't trust this trump vaccine i don't
trust it at all but
masks masks masks mass mass now here's
the reality
everywhere the virus has gotten bad
people mask up
there's lots of data to show this
wherever the when the virus got bad in
florida people masked at a higher rate
when the virus got bad in new york
people masked at a higher rate because
they thought that it was going to
protect them because people act
in self-preserving fashion it doesn't
matter to joe biden though because for
joe biden it's really about the virtue
signaling of suggesting he's going to
mandate
mask wearing because you can't trust
your neighbor you can't trust your
neighbor
now i wonder how many people really
believe that they cannot trust their
neighbor
and if they really believe that maybe
you shouldn't be out in public places
with neighbors who are like that
but joe biden is really putting heavy
focus on the mask and he's performing
serious alarmism in the process
he's really banking on kovit getting a
lot worse before the election
you can you can tell he is and so biden
now is trying to proclaim that his legal
team thinks he can push a nationwide
mass mandate there is no constitutional
authority to do this
he's changing his tune on this because
trump has rightly pointed out that when
joe biden and kamal o'hara say
we would love everyone to wear a mass
they don't have the authority to do that
so really it's just them
jabbering nonsensically now joe biden
has been roped into
saying that he might have the legal
authority to mandate that you are a mass
there is no such authority under the
constitution
there's a question i think it's and can
be answered in the positive
a question whether i can mandate
over state lines that every single state
has to comply
our legal team thinks i can do that
based upon the degree to which there's a
crisis
in those states and how bad things are
for the country
and if we don't do it what happens but i
would make the case
i'd make the case why it's necessary
um so he talked to governors is what he
says but
even the implication that he has the
constitutional authority to cram this
stuff down is not is not correct
obviously
okay meanwhile supposedly trump is the
is the person who is anti-science now
listen trump tweets out a bunch of stuff
and he has tweeted out a bunch of stuff
in the past that is anti-science
okay donald trump has tweeted out a
bunch of crap about vaccines that i find
absolutely absurd on every scientific
level
donald trump has not been i would say
friendly toward many of the findings of
science in the past
openly acknowledge this when it comes to
vaccines what donald trump says about
vaccines is significantly less dangerous
than what joe biden is saying about the
vaccines for this thing right now
here was donald trump yesterday saying
that biden should stop his anti-vaccine
nonsense
i'm calling on biden to stop
promoting his anti-vaccine theories
because all they're doing is hurting
the importance of what we're doing and i
know that if
they were in this position they'd be
saying how wonderful it is
they're recklessly endangering lives you
can't do that
and uh again this is really a case that
they're only talking just started
talking a little bit negatively and
that's only because they know we have it
or we will soon have it and the answer
to that is
very soon okay so there was this
controversy that broke out because
yesterday the cdc director robert
redfield made a couple of comments he
said there wouldn't be wide availability
of the vaccine
until the middle of next year and then
trump came back at him and he said no
it'll be available sooner
i think that what the controversy is
over is who the vaccine will go to
wide availability means like general
public availability but to the elderly
to the most vulnerable to healthcare
workers it's supposed to be available by
the end of the year i think pretty much
everybody
agrees on that at this point but
you know again the party of science not
being particularly scientific about
vaccines not being particularly
scientific about
covid and apparently in nashville openly
covering up information well openly
now it's open covering up information
about covet spread in new york shutting
down the schools
this is no longer scientific this is
political it's pretty obviously
political
which is why it was amazing to watch so
donald trump
yesterday he was he was in this presser
and
he was asked about the coveted response
and he says if you just look at the
at the red states the red states
actually did pretty well here he's not
wrong about this he got all sorts of
flack on it
here's what trump said so we're down
in this territory and that's despite the
fact that the blue states had
had tremendous death rates if you take
the blue states out we're
uh at a level that uh i don't think
anybody in the world would be at
we're really at a very low level but
some of the states uh
they were blue states and blue state
managed and by the way we would
recommend they open up their states i
think it's very important that they
open up their states people on the left
went nuts over this because he's the
president of all the states why is he
separating red and blue states this was
chris hayes take he couldn't just he
just couldn't believe it couldn't
believe it
if you take out the blue states well
then we're at a very low level if you
don't count the deaths of americans then
there's fewer american deaths if you're
a state that voted for hillary clinton
well then it's your fault i guess your
aunt's death it doesn't actually count
you see it's a message from the
president united states okay uh
the ire from chris hayes here let me
just point out that at the dnc they
literally had a woman whose father died
of covet
suggested her dad's out of cove because
he voted for trump the democrats have
been claiming for
this entire time that andrew cuomo is a
model of american governance while ron
desantis
is a a villain of history for his
handling
it was you guys who made this political
you're the ones who decided donald trump
was the worst president of all time
and andrew cuomo was the best governor
of all time to excuse andrew cuomo's
garbage governance or the fact that the
states that have been hit hardest are
almost universally democratic states
and to justify the fact that you guys
continue to back lockdown policies that
are ineffective at best and
extraordinarily damaging at worst
okay so you made it red versus blue you
did
it shouldn't be red versus blue it
should be everybody pursues the best
policy that is clearly not what is
happening
at this point the good news is again the
party of science is the party of science
and so nancy pelosi uh honestly she put
out an ad
yesterday saying that mother earth is
angry the party of science going full
on gaia pagan here here's nancy pelosi
speaker of the house put out putting out
an ad saying that mother earth is angry
at us that's what's happening here
mother earth is angry she's telling us
whether she's telling us with hurricanes
on the gulf coast fires in the west
that the climate crisis is real and has
an
impact 16 people have died in washington
oregon
and california including a firefighter
and a one-year-old baby
our firefighters have been so very okay
i'm sorry
the mother earth is angry crowd mother
earth is angry crowd men can be women
crowd babies inside the womb are not
babies
and hundreds of thousands of americans
are going to die by the end of the year
based on a study that was wrong in
nearly all of its specifics very early
on and now is putting in bad data again
and also vaccines are bad if they're
developed under the trump administration
spare me
spare me just a little bit just a little
bit alrighty we'll be back here
later today with a lot more content that
i didn't have a chance to get to
otherwise make sure that you come back
tomorrow for much much more
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick
chien the show is edited by adam syavets
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clinton